soap that smells like cat food and a
necklace that holds your wine glass it's
episode 12 of loot these USB rocky 3
drives do set ups while they're plugged
in but don't hold any memory even more
useless is this mustache for your bike
if you prefer scooters and you love
babies
pick up the stroller speeder bystanders
might judge you so protect your identity
with urban outfitters Censorship
sunglasses then up the danger value with
a police line scarf which right now is
unavailable but you can buy these cookie
cutters that will make you a ninja bread
man on XE you can pick up an NES
controller rug for 60 bucks or a $40
Batmobile for gigabyte memory stick
stinky bomb lets you lather your naked
body up with all kinds of great soap
shoes grenades the state of Ohio and my
favorite baby heads if you're lonely
send this card to your friends saying
that you miss them of course not with a
gun but with your Raygun sculpture put
this baby on your desk and let people
know that your guns the hottest one heat
in your mouth try out Tabasco family
reserve a twenty five dollar bottle aged
for more than twice as long as usual
made with premium white wine vinegar
previously shared only within the
Tabasco family but if real heat is more
your style think about this the hottest
Tabasco ever made ranks in at over 7,000
Scoville heat units but you can buy
faint geeks ghost pepper chili flakes
sprinkle them on your food and enjoy a
heat of over 1 million Scoville heat
units this Hello Kitty Rubik's Cube is
also a secret bank safe where you can
lock up your stash and cool material
cells a spray paint graffiti pen artisan
socks carries socks that are sharks
eating your legs you can also make your
feet uh ters with toe teeths or get
pantyhose that simulates full leg length
tattoos oh and don't forget these
incredible Elvis photo socks B and Elvis
on the go by punching guitar picks out
of
almost any gift card or credit card and
then the lean back and read neato shops
posters containing in micro letters
entire books like Alice in Wonderland
and The Wizard of Oz if you haven't
spent all your money keep it locked up
with fake dicks batman money clip I
leave you with t-shirts and a reminder
to subscribe to this channel Vsauce -
that way no sauce will leak through your
cracks and as always thanks for watching